With it's stimulating effects, it's easy to understand why coffee is the second most
Commodity trading on land after oil. For many, it keeps us awake and moving through our busy
days. But how does it work? What exactly does coffee do to your brain?
Whenever you are awake, a chemical called adenosine accumulates slowly in the brain.
This adenosine is associated with receptors that slow brain activity - eventually, and
The more adenosine there is, the more tired your brain feels. Which makes sense, as longer
I was awake, and more tired to become. On the contrary, when you sleep, focus
Of adenosine dips, gradually promote vigilance.
But it turns out that caffeine in your coffee is incredibly similar to adenosine
In the temple. Caffeine works it way through the bloodstream and into the brain,
Where it begins to compete and binds with adenosine receptors. But because it does not
Adenosine, and "drowsiness" effect is not felt. Adenosine can no longer be a predicament, that is
It dwindles soothing properties. Which is great for you when you feel
Tired! However, with the long-term use of caffeine, the brain responds by creating more adenosine
Receptors - which means more caffeine is required to get the same response. This also means
That when you try to quit drinking coffee or miss your daily intake, then you may encounter
Some withdrawal symptoms feel more tired than you would before you ever drink
coffee!
But caffeine does not stop there! It also stimulates the production of adrenaline
- As you know, fight or escape the hormone? This increases your heart rate and gets your blood
Pump, and even open your airways. Furthermore, it affects dopamine levels by preventing l
Absorbing into the brain, which makes you feel happy! In fact, this is exactly the same
The thing is not cocaine, just to a lesser degree. It's a drug, ins! This dopamine
Stimulation is also an aspect of coffee that makes it mildly addictive.
So you can drink a lot of coffee? It turns out there is a lethal dose of caffeine that
Somewhere around 150mg of caffeine per kilogram of body. That means if your weight
70KG that will need 14,000mg of caffeine for an overdose. Put in perspective, on average
A cup of coffee contains about 150mg of caffeine, meaning if you are 70KG, approximately 70
Cups of coffee will kill you. However, you should drink those cups every time you make
It is virtually impossible to overdose on caffeine from coffee, because you will not be able to
Very physically fit in your stomach. You want to start also suffer from mania and
Hallucinations before reaching this point.
Caffeine also contains halflife of about 6 hours - even if you drink standard coffee with about
150mg of caffeine, ie after about 6 hours there will be only 75mg left in your system and
You'll be feeling half-impact. And after 6 hours that, you will have 37.5mg - leave
More space for adenosine to jump back into motion. This is why you may arrive to another
Cup throughout the day, to maintain this glorious, alert and lively feeling.
So drink up! Enjoy the buzz ... while it lasts :)
And all of you at school, while we know caffeine is the key, so are good deals on textbooks!
So we have cooperated with SlugBooks.com to get the cheapest prices for books
you need. All you have to do is go to SlugBooks.com/AsapSCIENCE and search the ISBN number of your books
Look for. SlugBooks will then compare prices from around the network. Seriously, we know
How expensive textbooks can be, so hopefully this will save you some money! special thanks
For SlugBooks to support AsapSCIENCE.
Got the urgent question you want to answer?
Ask them in comments or on Facebook or Twitter.
Subscribe to get more weekly flag videos!